ladies and gentlemen we just heard from  Allen split he missed the off-ramp at  the Civic Center and he's somewhere in  Ensenada but he's on his way here our  next presenter is a child of Hollywood  was become one of its loveliest young  actresses her name is Jamie Lee Curtis  accompanying her is the debonair  contemporary version of Dracula George  Hamilton  the nominees for best achievement in  cinematography are Josep ero to know for  all that jazz Vittorio Storaro for  Apocalypse Now  Frank Phillips for the black hole  mr. Monroe's for Kramer vs Kramer and  William a Fraker for 1941  and the winner is Vittorio stop  ah Francis thank you thank you for the  trust that you gave me thank you for the  freedom you give me to express  completely myself in a public now thank  you